hello everyone and welcome to another
fun game you guys requested from round
two of the super bit chess classic it is
shakira mahadeva versus richard rapport
rapport as you know will be playing the
candidates tournament um
this year in in june i believe it starts
on 16th of june it actually starts on my
birthday uh so it's always nice when
when things work work out like that uh
it's gonna be it's gonna be a great
birthday uh but this game it's uh well
you guys requested it for good reasons
it's uh
very very
a lot of stuff is happening and you guys
will enjoy it so uh let's dive dive into
it uh mamitarov has the white pieces and
he opens with e4 we have e6 that upper
goes for the french defense also will be
very interesting if he will uh prepare
the french for the
uh for the candidates tournament uh like
i believe nippo did uh when he was
playing the previous candidates uh
tournament and that worked very well for
him uh we have d for d5 and not knight
to c3 and here the standard replies
bishop to b for just going for the
winner variation and this is i believe
by far the most analyzed uh
of the of the responses but here we have
knight to c6 already a very very rare
continuation by rapport uh in in terms
of rarity for example bishop to b4 has
over 40 000 uh top level games in the
database were as nice to c6 says about a
thousand so here we have e5 by shahriar
and now f6 immediately uh tackling the
center here queen h5 doesn't really do
all that much you're just going to block
it with the g6 so emma majero continues
developing bishop to b5 and now
bishop to d7 is what's again usually
played here but that upper place queen
to d7 he's saying if you trade here and
you most likely will i'm gonna capture
with the queen and i'm gonna have a
queen nicely placed on c6 which is um
not that common knight to f3 uh we have
a6 challenging the bishop and now bishop
captures on c6
uh we have to mention that
well did his research
most likely i believe and uh rapport
plays this line quite a lot and he has
um two two uh very very good games in
this line uh one where he actually uh uh
faced bishop captures in c six and one
where his opponent retreated with the
bishop to d3 this was in 2017 in
defeated world cup against the afghani
nir where nair played bishop to d3 the
game ended in the draw uh but momodarov
decides to go for bishop captures um at
night on c6 queen captures and now again
there is a game from 2014 from the
gibraltar
masters where e captures on f6 was
played this was played
between eric hanson and and and the
rihard rapper there uh and again that
the game ended in a draw but here we
have castles and now we deviate from the
games that rapport actually played in
this opening uh and uh there is a game
where bishop to d7 was played it was
played in the game orientation versus
thomas randall in 2020 at that 31 but
here we have knight to e7 and it is now
already as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game as we can see how
rapport uh brought some very very
refreshing uh ideas to the tournament uh
and okay now the knight no longer uh
controls the f6 squares thermometer of
just captures he says all right i will
ruin your pawn structure on the king's
side i believe this is good for me why
why wouldn't it be g captures on f6 and
now of course we want to get this check
in so we move the knight knight to h4 uh
and of course rapper prevents this he
plays the h5 he needs to
prevent not just queen g4 but also queen
to h5 we have queen to f3 going after
the f6 pawn and not just bishop to g7 it
seems uh
weird but if it works why not
uh and here
upon the b3 number wants to develop his
dark square bishop to this very strong
diagonal but he has to keep an eye on
the knight only the queen from f3 is
guarding the knight on c3 so here e5 now
uh
rapper wants to
attack the queen with pawn to e4 then
you will have
well quite a few squares to keep
defending your knight uh and here
capturing uh is just uh resigns
basically if you capture we're going to
capture here and now look at this this
is i mean how do you how do you play the
c4 once once that happens it's game over
uh so you're going to have to play some
like bishop b2 e4 and then d4 and then
well yeah it's this is unplayable so
mavidarov goes for the immediate the
bishop to a3 puts pressure on the knight
and now bishop to g4 tackling the queen
queen to g3 and now rook the g8 rapper
is going uh all out here uh he he he
wants to attack mamadoro's king uh
bishop captures on e7 uh not allowing
black the the castle keeping the king in
the center of the board the king
captures and now rook eight to e1 now
mamodarov says all right i mean your uh
play is very very
impressive but uh i mean your king is on
e7 how are you how are you going to
survive this uh well rapper just plays
e4 he keeps the center uh keeps the
center closed and uh f3 is not possible
here because if you play f3 then the
queen no longer guards the knight we
just capture and now okay you can
capture on g4 but we just trade captures
characters captures black black is up
upon also black's pawn structure is
better he has a bishop against tonight
uh so uh robert would be would be better
here so after this e4 idea we have
knight to a for by mommy thereof now f3
definitely is a threat so you have to be
careful what you play but uh here rapper
just plays f5 he gives up uh
a little bit of material but he wants to
he wants to attack here we have f3 now
attacking the bishop now bishop captures
on d4 uh grabbing that pawn uh we have
king to h1 and now pawn to f4 attacking
the queen forcing the queen to grab the
pawn here queen captures on f4 and now
rook a to f8 and now all of rapport's
pieces are fully mobilized and uh well
it uh does not look does not look good
for mahmoud but he plays queen to d2
this is the only good move you have to
move the queen with temple you attack
the bishop but rapper does the same
bishop to f6 attacks the knight and now
f captures an e4 of course you could
capture here but then bishop captures
here not much is happening here with
capturing an e4 you are now threatening
e captures on d5 opening up a discovery
and winning the queen so here d captures
on e4 and now what do you play the pawn
is defended here but this is exactly the
position from the thumbnail and here uh
mamadaru goes for rook captures
on e4 he gives up the two rooks for the
queen uh there is no good move here
other than to capture the rook if you
move the
move the king we just defend the rook
and i mean black is just uh
the black king is just in a terrible
terrible uh situation so after rook
captures an e4 with check queen captures
and now of course we attacked the queen
rook to e1 and now there's no way to
save the queen so queen captures any one
with check queen captures on e1 and now
king the d8 sidestepping check and um
it's a really really tricky position uh
mamiyarov has a queen but rapport has a
bishop player in the rook pair and if
momidarov does not play a a certain move
that uh
saves him the game it's gonna be it's
gonna be game over basically so feel
free to pause the video and try to spot
this only move that does not lose the
game for mom and darf while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
back rank is just uh
our our weakest weakest spot and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is ponte h3 uh we just have to
give our king a little uh breeding room
here and that's what will save us and
that's exactly what mom and dad have
played to give you an example if you
play something like knight c5 makes
sense you control these squares you want
to not that obviously you want to try
and uh
do something okay the bishop guards d7
but it's it's a nice move controls a lot
of squares just bishop c3 and white
resigns uh you if you capture the bishop
rook f1 will be checkmate uh if you
don't we can always uh
put the bishop on e2 then play rook to
f1 so h3 is just the move you really
have to play here so h3 was played and
now again a rapper has to be careful and
he plays bishop captures an h3 this is
the absolute best it opens up the g file
for the rook and uh well you will either
uh just checkmate the white king or win
back the queen so g captures an h3
bishop to d4 now threatening rook to g1
especially if the queen moves then rook
to g1 is checkmate uh but uh i mean even
even with the queen here you will now
give up the rook and bishop for for the
queen because then you will have a rook
against two knights and two knights
don't really coordinate all that well so
here we have queen to d1 uh here maderov
even forces this trade and now the
bishop cannot be saved of course c5 is
nothing we can just attack it or play c3
uh so just rook to g1 with check queen
captures bishop captures in the now king
captures and g1 and we get this position
where um we have three pawns on the
queen side each one pawn on the king
side each and it's two knights against
the rogue but you can see uh the two
knights placed on on both rims uh you uh
there's the old thing of course the
knight and the rim is grim or dim or you
know everyone has a different idea what
the knight on the on the
rim is uh but here two nights uh that's
just uh there's just no not enough time
to start coordinating so here rook to f4
attacking the knight here knight g2 and
now of course rook to f3 going after
this spawn
we have h4 and now just b6 and here you
can see how the rook wonderfully
controls everything the knight can't go
here the knight can't go here the king
can go here or here if this knight moves
then we just go after the pawn again so
that's obviously not going to work so
what can you play here well uh knight to
b2 but now uh we gain access to the c3
square and now we can go after the c2
pawn so rook to c3 now comes knight to
e1 we defend the pawn but now this pawn
is undefended so mama there are just
attacks uh rapper just attacks it rook
to h3 knights to g2 now comes rook to c3
again we attacked this mommy there of
defense rook knights d1 rook to h3
knights the g2 and he was in the um in
this position on move 37 that mamadar of
andhra port agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here so really
really uh brutal brutal game worthy of a
worthy of uh uh 20 2800 um
uh okay uh
rapport is not in the 2800 club major is
a former 2800 but uh still very very
high level game and even though uh you
know pieces were just flying everywhere
uh uh
two rooks uh
left the queen left the board basically
for two rooks uh the evaluation of the
engine never really went uh more than
0.3 0.0.4 but that's that's not not
enough to try and push for anything so
really a top-level game very very
exciting stuff rapper to really uh you
know he he brought the big guns for this
one already a completely new game on
move eight uh here i mean
uh not something you you see every day
after this knight 87 but mommy are
obviously prepared very well he knew
that rapport
was fond of this line of the of the
french from time to time uh and uh well
he i did not have all that all that many
problems uh yeah and that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it as a lot of you
have requested it i would like to thank
michael colbert asher fine joshua hadley
queen scene and bonafide verto for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this wonderful event until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day